نزحنا من السلاطين ابو عاصي ابو عاصي جينا
هان على الشمال جينا على خانيونس على
الهلال طلعنا من خانيونس ماقدرش يطلع فبعد
يومين ثلاثه طلع اجانا على وين على
المواسط خان يونس هوول انا معي امانه بدي
راح ارجعها قلنا له ما تروحش الوضع خطير
ماردش باقين طخين ايش طلق فيراس جناش
الخبر امبارح اجنا اليوم الخبر الساعه 6
الصبح حسبي الله وانت نعم الوكيل اخ هذا
ظلم هذا 95% جاب في توجيهي هذا هذا يمكن
احسن واحد فينا اخواتي هي الام تمان اولاد
احنا تخاف عليه من الطير الطاير مش قادرين
نتحمل الماساه اللي احنا فيها يعني نطلع
مش قادر كان اخوي هذا 24 ساعه معاي ايش
بدي اقوللك هذا مش احتلال هذا عدو بقتل
بدون ما يعرف ايش السبب خلص هذا مواطن لاج
بدي
اقتله
ا